[Music]
it's an area the size of India frozen
and inaccessible for most of the year
Russia's Arctic territory is one of the
least hospitable places on earth and
ability ominous or agrees emergency mode
first a young lady mr. assets authority
but Russia's extreme cold is also deeply
embedded in the mindset of its people
even teachers rupture escucha occur on
that do store no seriousness art since
imperial times Russian rulers have seen
size as a source of strength and wealth
compelling them against all odds to
settle the country's northern reaches
over the last decade President Vladimir
Putin has revived Russia's Arctic dream
boosted by a warming climate and melting
ice that has opened up the potentially
lucrative northern sea route his
government has declared the Arctic a
strategic energy battleground can you
stop at Alinea
who bailed out well she was more than
steel but the success of the route is
not guaranteed the far north is a land
of unforgiving extremes tixi a former
transport hub in Northeast Siberia that
is going through a drastic economic
decline is living proof that the rich is
beneath the Arctic ice are a world away
from most of the settlements above it
can Russia ever make it work 1/5 of the
country's territory is here in the
Arctic Circle although most of this land
is unfit for human habitation Russia's
rulers have long been obsessed with
settling and industrializing the north
in pursuit of the riches beneath the
Arctic sighs including oil gas gold and
rare earths they've often shown little
regard for the costs of this pursuit the
Soviet ideology never explicitly is
asked the question whether the
development of the remote territories
was profitable or rationale economically
was taken as a truth in itself that
development of space is a positive
phenomenon but the North is more than
just a source of wealth Russia has a
long history of favoring extensive
spatial development from Imperial times
this was practically a state idea to
colonize vast territories to expand the
border during the Soviet era extracting
resources from the north depended almost
wholly on forced labour socialist
dictator Joseph Stalin tried to overcome
the odds of nature by sheer power of
will and a coercive political system
inmates of labour camps were worked to
death building roads and railways and
digging Siberia's riches out of the
ground in the end of the fortress when
maybe the greatest amount of this and
free labor was used it was about 8 or 6%
upper to all the labor force in in
Russia in Soviet Union but in these
northern regions it was almost two
thirds of labor force was on three tens
of thousands of people are believed to
have died in gulag camps in a far north
alone but much of the sacrifice was in
vain many of the industrial plants mines
and railways built under the brutal
gulag system fell into disrepair when
the Soviet Union collapsed but President
Putin's rise to power
has sparked a revival of Russia's octa
conditions
his government has declared the Arctic a
strategic energy battleground and has
started rebuilding Russia's military
presence there a polar expedition in
2007 even planted a Russian flag on the
Arctic seabed provoking international
criticism last year Moscow set up a
government Commission to manage Arctic
policy and launched an economic
development plan for the region Putin's
revival of Russia's Arctic dream rests
largely on an unlikely force climate
change rising temperatures and melting
sea ice are fueling hopes within Russia
that is on the verge of acquiring a
viable shipping lane along its entire
northern coast
the white zone was more nasty plumbing
is just missing magorium Australia hope
our initiative a purchase option a
mystery rupee I see in 2012
the extent of Arctic sea ice at the end
of the summer melting season dropped to
a record low 44 percent below the
average of the previous three decades
the NSR shortens the shipping distance
between yo Kharma and hamburg by up to
4,000 100 nautical miles a 37 percent
reduction compared to the route that
travels through this Suez Canal from
Asia to Europe
Moscow hopes to attract big flows of
international traffic along the NSR this
could help fund resource exploration and
infrastructure development in Russia's
more isolated Arctic areas
some places in the Russian far north are
prospering rich gas deposits under the
tundra in North West Siberia have fueled
the growth of novia warm gooey and
transformed the city into a magnet for
migrant workers no rookie geography yeah
no namuci topography las casas de la
presse even um each dollar bottom was
party cadabra's dmitriev an odd
schoolboy dream of leaving his town on
the Volga River to travel to the Arctic
became a reality 14 years ago amid miles
of swampland Nova would enjoy is a
thriving city of a hundred and thirteen
thousand people in North West Siberia it
has a modern shopping mall to rival any
in Moscow state-of-the-art sports
facilities and apartment buildings
sprouting up to house its growing
population the city is reaping the
benefits of the gas flowing beneath the
tundra surrounding it novio enjoy is the
hub from which Gazprom runs three giant
fields that account for half of Russia's
gas production it is also a stopover for
shift workers headed for the better a
large site on the Yamal Peninsula
northwest of Navi or enjoy where Nova
Tech is developing gas reserves with
French and Chinese partners Dmitry works
as a safety engineer three hours north
of Novi or enjoy life at the workers
camp is fairly basic Dmitry and most
others employed in the gas industry in
North Western Siberia work on shift
rotations usually 30 days on and 30 days
off
Nico vouilloz magnet remote emotion
rubato porchetta Pahlavi's moscow
presentó this acoustic interpreter
demoted or supposed Autocode ito Simeon
companies pay their staff at least 80
percent more than elsewhere in Russia
and workers are offered free flights
home since the city was established in
the 1980s companies like Nova tech and
state-run Gazprom have paid for its
development they sponsor huge facilities
and schools during the bring labor into
uncomfortable environments it's always
costly have to compensate people and
that's why in the
cases in other countries in market
economies when we see development of
resources in remote areas we see that
they are done in the less
labor-intensive way novio boy is a
bright spot in Russia's vast frozen
Arctic territory it could be an example
for future developments in the region if
factors such as climate change and the
price of oil and gas spur more
investment but for now the city is an
exception the reality of most other
settlements in the Russian Arctic is
much bleaker distri chess Telugu lady
Dean Pony Astana Kaduna slog metal roma
move idly the brush dama is material
Navy ship at our cameras Grozny I do
male Camogli Brigitte illusion cutter
Bruce Lee TV show Yahoo Leslie Yuri
hrushevskiy is 22 years old and was born
and raised in tixi
a small town in eastern Siberia more
than a thousand kilometers from the
nearest city after a brief stint away at
university he dropped out and returned
home to save money bringing his sim
Petersburg born girlfriend Natalya with
him / - the kidney I'm no suspicious
Linea Motel wouldn't know where
absolutely the boy was though eluded
north of rain minimal Kenya Schneider
which he had now Brosnan young which the
Lord number of Ouray works with his
father an engineer at a local Research
Station Natalya hangs out at taxis only
recreational center and in the evenings
they watch TV series together or take
long walks in the hills surrounding the
town tixi is just a speck in the three
and a half million square kilometers
that make up the Russian Arctic it once
stood for all that Russia is spired - in
the Arctic built in 1933 under the rule
of Stalin it was a bustling port on the
and see root but the end of socialism
led to the collapse of shipping traffic
on the route and to Texas decline in
less than 30 years the town's population
has plummeted by 60%
yes Anna Vashti aah whistles boy Yahoo
today mr. sexy will give a warning sir
- Tony for the daughters of Nepal
Collette - gorgeous
Courtney cannot see digit information is
allowed sense - Mysti Ghidorah central
name arctic air Bua viscosity no studied
central narcotics in a new suit of
urinals Alexander goo cough is one of
the few scientists who remain in the
area he's opened a museum here
showcasing species plucked from the
surrounding tundra although he loves his
work he misses the once vibrant tixi
that existed in the Soviet era
Alexander's nostalgia for ticks his
glory days is shared among many of the
town's older residents who can only hope
the Russian government reinvests Y
planned ahead is a program bucket or a
poem a modern is Archie Moscow port
oppression News tiene una vaca destiny
voce Sarojini immerse comport oh no - to
Nestor Canada attack Nicodemus over to
the narrow bottle promotions tzedakah
Cota
president noble disease somewhere Moscow
predictions are important once the
Soviet Union collapsed state money to
support industries like coal here in
taxi dried up this coal mine that you
can see right behind me which used to
attract people from all over the Soviet
Union for work now lies in ruins
one thing that is growing in tixi is
Russia's military Nikita kudos off the
son of a former Air Force pilot who
served in tixi most of his life works at
the local military base his 18 year old
girlfriend Ludmila moved here four years
ago with her mother and stepfather were
made chokers shown as this [ __ ] blue
semen and a civil war message to appear
walk by okay we do this microRNA what
she's crossing Apollo 11
we deal in that UAV accord shocker Tosca
[Music]
park in-seok mookie massacre possession
so Curtis Kayla eldona three mr. de
Lucia resistivity onto almost vanish
kapakos sedusa Cruz was brutal
marketable area when you'd Miller and
her mother
Liliana arrived in the winter of 2012 a
pipe at the town's diesel generator
ruptured cutting the water supply the
airport was also closed for repairs
which triggered a full-blown food crisis
that lasted seven months the government
has funded some basic improvements
including a new heating plant and
repairs to power lines while military
personnel in tixi can enjoy relative
financial security the abandoned
buildings dotting the town and the
ship's frozen in the ice along Texas
shoreline remind its residents of a lost
opportunity at the moment tixi is a
world away from the prosperous Arctic
imagined by Putin many of the
government's promises to invest have
been slow to materialize and Putin's
efforts to boost Russia's geopolitical
power on other fronts in recent years
have diverted money that could have been
spent developing the Arctic
the pun of postage indexical Salmonella
two creams I shall position which we
showed you with instead Regina surely
let us return receive any hotel Moscow's
renewed interest in the Arctic has fund
hopes in places like tick see that the
town can prosper again so far though the
promise of the northern sea route as a
catalyst for developing the Russian
Arctic has failed to deliver
after a brief spike of NSR journeys
between Europe and Asia in 2012 and 2013
these so-called transits have almost
completely stopped again with oil prices
so low the fuel savings aren't enough to
convince foreign shipping companies that
this route is preferable to transiting
the Suez Canal
the only hope is that exports of
resources from the Russian Arctic will
revive the route but Arctic offshore
exploration is expensive and sanctions
against Russia borrowed from buying
Western equipment needed for offshore
drilling right now the tide seems to be
flowing against virgins plans but the
emotional pole to the north which many
Russians feel will continue to fuel
Moscow's Arctic ambition Yahweh lemon
yeah
opteka Bala Virata reason knowledge
during Paris away Arctic Africa move
option where to boost well kiss kiss
Lu Zhi Cheng cockroach Elsa machinist
for movie for mention apricots blue
diesel oil precursor Annie Lamott excuse
warrior near eroded
Russia's approach to developing the far
north has become much more pragmatic but
the Arctic is too vast and its resources
are too tempting for Moscow to give up
its three
Vladimir Putin is not the first Russian
ruler to try to conquer the Arctic and
he is unlikely to be the last
[Music]
you
you